et au brésil à présent le pays est
touché par une troisième vague de covin
le triste cap des 500 milles morts a été
franchi la population s'inquiète face à
une recrudescence des cas les détails
depuis sao paulo avec hugo stallone à
vie après avoir franchi samedi dernier
le seuil de 500 mille morts le brésil a
battu hier un nouveau et triste record
plus de 5 15 mille nouveaux cas
d'infection aux convives 19 ont été
recensés en 24 heures confirmant
l'arrivée d'une troisième vague alors
que la deuxième n'était pas vraiment
fini le nombre d'infections quotidienne
est en hausse constante depuis plus d'un
mois et de la moyenne de décès tourne
autour de 2000 par jour depuis la
semaine dernière mais ce qui inquiète
les médecins et les chercheurs
spécialistes c'est surtout un nouvel
effondrement du système de santé la
situation est déjà critique dans 19 des
27 états brésiliens avec plus de 80 %
d'occupation des lits en réanimation le
même 90% dans lui d'entre eux quant à la
vaccination les chiffres avance encore
trop lentement seuls 30 % de la
population a reçu au moins une dose et
11% et complètement vaccinés à 100 voire
l'eau par exemple la plus grande ville
du pays où je me trouve actuellement la
vaccination a dû être interrompu mardi
faute de deux disponibles et malgré la
situation sanitaire préoccupante la vie
semble être pratiquement revenue à la
normale dans la plupart des villes du
pays avec des restaurants des bars et
des commerces au vert et un grand nombre
de personnes sans masque dans les rues
un comportement encouragé par les
déclarations du président jaillir wolson
arrow qui n'a cessé de minimiser la
dangerosité du virus de remettre en
cause les mesures de restriction prises
par les maires et les gouverneurs
brésilien